It's 9 a.m. and we are about to board on the plane for Shikoku.
We are in Tokyo Haneda domestic airport.
We are attending the bi-yearly seminar of Chiba Sensei in Wakimachi
The group from Tokyo usually consists of 5 to 10 people
We are going there to train non-stop for 2 days,
then heading straight back to the plane and back to work.
Based on what he will show during these two days, we have months worth of study material.
We are going to board in 5 minutes so see you later!
The flight will take about an hour.
Here we are in Tokushima, the main city on Shikoku island.
We are still at the airport, waiting for our rental car to go to Wakimachi.
But before we go, I wanted to show you these statues of Awa-odori dancers.
It's a traditional Japanese dance and Tokushima is where it came from.
There is a very big festival here every August with hundreds of traditional dancers like these.
So maybe we'll come back later and make a little video about that.
I was born in 1931.
I'm 82.
Sensei, where were you born?
Here.
How did I start [Budo]?
Well...
because it was fun!
It was when World Ward II started.
The schools had been turned into cultural centers
and some were teaching Budo.
Just next door, there was a dojo.
They were doing Judo and Kendo.
But Kendo, with the sword, the armor, and all that, it was kind of a pain.
So I prefered to do Judo.
For the New Year,
we had the hatsu-geiko [first training of the year].
These were a rare occasion to eat nice things
because we usually didn't have much.
We deserved it because the Judo falls were really painful.
We used to throw each other like that!
That is how I started.
I was in elementary school [at age 7 or 8].
We used to wear the armor, and use the shinai,
you know, the Kendo gear.
We just put on the gear like that,
we did not have tenugi [towels] at the school.
We just put the helmet on bare head and whenever we got hit,
it hurt like hell!
It was the same for the shinai.
Inside,
we put rolled newspaper between the bamboo blades,
and tied them very tightly.
When we got hit on the head or the forearms,
it hurt a lot.
That is how we used to practice.
After that I returned to Judo.
But my Sensei told me:
"Judo is great but"
"before, we used to have atemi"
"but if you don't give atemi, your partner won't fall"
So we started using atemi.
Like that!
And from there,
he told me to enroll in another school,
and it was Daito-ryu.
But soon after I got a letter from the army.
It said:
"Apt for armed service."
It was written:
"Assault troops schools."
That is what it said.
I got it three months before the end of the war.
It was an appeal for volunteers.
To enroll, you had to undergo a physical examination,
but when I got there,
the Emperor had declared the surrender of Japan.
That is what must have happened but I did not know anything at the time.
These were strange times.
I heard from someone that the war was over.
I thought: "That's it, we lost"
Then you came back here?
There was no point being a volunteer anymore.
And from then on, we had nothing.
Money was worth nothing.
Standing face to face,
this technique is from ippondori but it is also found in 5-kajo,
because there are many different ways to do this.
So we take a guard like this right?
Like this...
This is the way we do it in Daito-ryu.
Doing it directly is quite unusual.
But in kamae...
you raise like this, from there...
but not like that!
If you open your elbow, your opponent can enter.
Like this, shaving motion,
so you can enter,
and from that point, take uke's center.
From there, cut.
This is suburi [cut].
That is how we do it.
From then on, I started Daito-ryu.
I heard about a place where they practiced Daito-ryu,
so I went to visit it.
I was told it was the office of someone named Nakatsu [Heizaburo].
He was a 6th Dan [Kodokan] Judo
He was one of the 6 experts who went to protect the Asahi newspaper.
The team had been put together by Ishii Mitsujiro
because the newspaper had been attacked three times [by right wing terrorists].
Takuma Hisa Sensei was the head of security there.
It is also the time when Ueshiba Morihei was asked [by Ishii] to come to the journal
because he knew violent koryu techniques.
It lasted 5 years
and from the 6th, it was called Asahi-ryu.
So the techniques that are in the Takumakai's Soden
corresponding to these first 5 years are those taught by Ueshiba.
The picture collection.
From that point,
Takeda Sokaku arrived.
And Ueshiba returnerd to Tokyo...
Ueshiba took his students with him.
From then on, Takeda Sokaku took over the teaching at the journal.
The rest of the Soden pictures represent that.
This was before Chiba Sensei's time.
Before they met [Nakatsu and Chiba]
So this is the start of the period with Takeda Sokaku
and the master-disciple transmission with Nakatsu Sensei.
It was a long time ago but they had cameras
that they used at the journal.
Imagine that, click! click!
This is how they took all these pictures,
there must have been thousands of them.
All of very high quality for the time.
It is because they were at a newspaper that they could do it,
but even there, people complained.
There were gossips
because they were using large amounts of film.
They took pictures during the breaks.
Click! Click! Click!
They did it by pretexting that since the practice had been intense,
Sensei had to go for a bath.
And they took these pictures in the meantime behind his back.
But I think he probably wasn't fooled by it.
They were taking pictures of techniques that they were doing for the first time
so these were not much use as learning tools, but just reminders of the new forms.
You cannot understand these picturs alone.
This means that atemi is essential.
You use it to make your opponent move.
Not like this! You have to get through!
It all happens on the elbow joint.
Go this way,
and that is how you end up there.
And then, another atemi on the head!
And you exit like this.
Then Nakatsu Sensei retired from the Asahi journal.
Since he was from Ikeda, he came back here.
He setup a small dojo in his chiropractic cabinet.
It was in the waiting room, a very small place.
It was about 4 square meters.
On the other side, there was the treatment room.
It was for those with dislocated jaws,
or hurt joints and broken bones.
In the waiting room of his cabinet,
there were no X-rays at the time,
so you had to touch to make a diagnostic, based form experience.
We had to make do with what little we had.
We diagnosed like that and tried to put things back together.
We used to secure the hips of the patient
to prevent messing him up.
It was like that at the time.
Did Nakatsu Sensei do any advertizing to get students?
Not at all, he would never have done that!
For him, anybody was suitable.
"Go ahead"
It was always "Go ahead" with him.
He liked to drink with someone,
but there was not a lot [of alcohol] at the time,
that a the way to make him happy.
Black market sake right?
So I brought some to him, telling him to use as he pleased,
and he said "Thank you".
That is how I started.
I knew how to do shikko [moving on one's knees]
and he used to say "One has to start with shikko"
I had done Judo, Kendo, and a lot of other things...
Your body was well conditioned.
Yes, and I was amongst the tallest people at the time.
We used to train in the field at the back over there.
Outside?
On the ground.
There were some stones so it hurt when we fell.
There used to be a sewing school there,
so sometimes, there were needles on the ground.
It hurt a lot!
Now there are tatami so it is like practicing on pillows.
You never injured yourselves?
We had nothing at that time,
but the wooden floor was flexible enough so we were ok.
We bounced like on cushions!
We wanted a sandbag but we had no money.
It was expensive.
So we used to take a big grain bag,
and fill it with gravel.
We used to charge into it,
like rugby players.
We went that far in order to train.